また
衛兵
今日映画見に行ったんだけど貸切だった4 dx って人気ないのかな
ありますね deko 揺れたり身体全体で感じる映画館の4 dx ってのがあるん
ですけど
普通に沈め見たいよねこんにちははじめ社長です皆さんこのメーカーでご存じでしょう
かこれで生肝の女だねと言いまして目線が90度変わるメガネなんですよ
簡単に言うとこうやって来て付けますと中の人間目線はまっすぐなんですけれども
q ちょっと変わるのでましたが見えています御剣がまっすぐ見てるともですけどここ
でね見えてますドライバー小子どもの家
ます紙幣向きながらでも書いた方が読めるっていうそういう仕組みになっていても便利
というか身体が疲れにくいらしいですでなま毛モノメガネっていうものがあるんです
けどこれ
9ちょっと自分の目線がか俺ってことはつけてべ線がこうなっていますねここに
盛り込んでおくと90万あってここでもう1個置くと90マカルト元に戻っちゃうん
ですよおいてみましょうか
やってみると今じゃ
じゃバッチに見えてますそこそれだとやってカメラの前が見えてるんですけど
作るとご覧くださいましたのサングラスが見えますね
でこれらは下に動いたサングラソーほらまたまっすぐに戻っていますこれは
いける目線のたけど救助を変更するのでこれたくさん準備したらひょっとしたらイヤに
入るだけでもこの角度を利用してパンパンパンッ
きょきょうってこう90度90度って曲がりまくったら編って剃ってるだけでもあの
あゆヘアのすべてを把握することは可能ではないのかと思いまして今回この日での
たくさん買いました
要するに目線が宮中と変われってことはこの宮中と変わったさっきにもう一個目なに
置いておくと落ちた店がまた待って救助と変わるってこのさっきにまた買って置いて
おくと
更新チャンスがまたこうやって来ずが変わるっていうことはですよこうやっても買った
やつを片方救助にを上げてこちらが鉄を買って救助に負けて曲がってゾーン残って曲げ
てあげてってこのメールをたくさんで90度負け
続けるとそうかここに沿っているだけで360度の視野が身につくと思いました
8多分マジでつ身に付きます一家にほど90と目線が変わる目がにをうまいこと配置
するかによってこの編入で僕は上下右左
前後ろ頭から殴られてもきっと技を交わせるような天才的な
メディアを身につけることで言うと思うんですが今回はしっかりと配置を考えて90度
ミーティングかるめがではおいてこの家でんん
最強を目指そうと思います
暗い子まず両サイドを見たいからこうすればとかおおぉすげぇやちょっと左が見えてれ
ば普通に磨こう向いてみて本当に生かしたにてっつ覚えてキャンつってパトこっちに
つければ右が見えるようになりました
あーをかけ見えました見えました今これで右のここがを北半球できてます
歳以上です
またからくっつける必要あるかなぁこれでもくっつける必要ないですよ
me
tan
car
me
はいというわけでようやく完成しました僕はここでちょっと首を動かしたり使えること
によってこの部屋のあらゆる場所を確認することが可能でございます舞方向を確認する
が普通にこえーわまっすぐ見えるので前4個あっクリア
後ろ方向拡充するときはこちらですこちらを見ることによってこっちに次目線ができ
ますってこうやっていくと
狼煙 lossless
確認できるんですけどば後ろからさらに左に9 please を利用してこっちがを
見ることが可能でございます
右後ろまでてみればこっちもなぜこうすることによって自分の後ろ側左側の後ろにいる
んですけど
バーンと子供一個4こちらにもメガネがセットしてありますこうすることによって家
だり後ろも全部確認することができますこっちのレンズみたら右が見えてフォトメ
レーズを見ると左が見えますコツ
音ズレと右前が見えますこっち2分で終えていくと骨の0時に入ってこっからさんに
ピョンて右前が全部確認できますでにも同様ですこっちが反射施工持っていくと
ここで様の救助が曲がるので左前ここらへんが確認できますさあもう見えてますねイギ
ウエが見えます左上が見えてます妄想名が見えてますやっぱり一番心配なのかまぁ
でですね上からの襲撃もあり得るのでえっとまずまし食べてみます得ることによって
こっちが版さしてこっち90度分かります別にこっちでこの馬上に行きますこれでなぜ
これでまずいうはクリアーですさあ
この部屋の入り口入り口を確認するためにくいっと上げると
これでさらに90度回転して入り口の奥まで見ることが可能でございます
i 取り上で今の俺に近くはない
今の僕だったら多分音なぜの状況で襲撃者が来て税法こうみえてるんですぐ捉えて対峙
することができます良ければから襲撃者に来てもらうんですけども音が無い状況僕は
ここでも首をちょっとしか動きませんそれで襲撃者に反応
してボクは衝撃ちゃんを返り討ちにしてありますそれにそういうしてお願いしますでは
行きます
[音楽]
お願いします
by ame
me
uh
バッハ
何も見えかっん